[Music]
this is amazing it's my childhood all
over again
Oh Tim I've got a confession to make one
of my guiltiest guiltiest pleasures is
cheesin and your pasty on the way home
from the pub I too am a lover of the
pasty although I've also traveled down a
Cornwall quite a lot I mean they are so
keen on the authenticity of the pasty
and they're very good reasons for it I
mean it's a it's a it's a phenomenal
thing it's a great way of cooking
there's a French technique called on
poppy yacht you may have seen it in a
restaurant where they they bring a kind
of an envelope made of greaseproof paper
to the table and they open it up and
inside vegetable usually fish that
sometimes like meat have been gently
steamed with aromatic vegetables and
wine and things like that and it's
delicious it's absolutely and that's
precisely what they did with the plastic
during the cooking process just about 40
minutes basically everything inside
steams to perfection so are you telling
me that a past years are a fine thing in
terms of the technique involved it uses
the same technique as something that is
incredibly refined under say right here
in fact we are not going to make Cornish
Pasties everybody in Cornwall span down
okay Cornish style pasty no no I've seen
that we can't say that you're from new
commerce or something on I've got
another confession to make
I also adore a Gregg's pasty and so you
can take a boy out of the Northeast you
cannot take the Northeast out so what
have you got there I've got some
shortcrust pastry which I've just bought
from the supermarket no shame in there
break it roughly into five balls
we're behaving like Cornish housewives
here so they don't have to worry about
how to measure it we are although I'm
sure I'm gonna get a lesson after the
Cornish housewife saying I measure
everything to the gram
damn it I'm doing the the beta version
of it so what veg would typically go
into a Cornish pasty
I think there's room for variation I
think they even admit that in Cornwall
you do need potato onions there's got to
be sweet for me the really really
authentic thing that gives the really
English sort of butcher shop flavor to
it is white pepper please beef in some
of mine
hada in some point what's going to give
it the meatiness what might replace it a
beef you're gonna use in yours would
Marmite do the job yeah I'll be great
honey herds let's go for some time
that's pretty English I'm gonna cut
about 100 grams each of one centimeter
dice the potatoes carrots mix them up
we're not gonna cook any of this so even
though we're not mine I'm just put in a
bowl you want to choose things that are
roughly of the same density I suppose
and you want to cut on the same size
pretty much everything is balanced yeah
they're all root vegetables are all
quite firm so nothing is going to kind
of fall apart and get too mushy so
hundred grams of carrot hundred grams of
potatoes and the grams of Swede roughly
I'm doing a set for a little bit of prep
here I'm very very finely shredding the
green of a leek to go with my capacity
so the potatoes the carrots the Swede
and the onion all together just mixed up
in a pot just separating a little bit
out for my havoc experiment I've
realized over the last couple of weeks
of what we've been doing has been really
quite loosely wired yeah that's what
cooking should be about is I've heard
some really good things I hope you have
as well so it's absolutely taking the
skin off my piece of smoked haddock and
I'm gonna cut back into 1-inch cubes as
well before I might try and recreate the
Greg's cheese and onion delight as well
great okay and I'm using a cut of beef
called skirt you need a saw an expensive
cut in a fast meal in the floor no no no
scratches the one or two balls as well
I've got one for my Cornish style
vegetable pasty and I'm doing one for my
cheese and onion pasty which is the
thing that I used to eat on the way home
from the pub into that one I'm just
putting potatoes and onions for now into
the Cornish style vegetable pass the
bowl a teaspoon of Marmite peppered
radically different to black pepper it's
just that is it kind of more of an
aesthetic thing you're immediately
transferred to a sort of a butcher shop
in the 1970s it's like a sausage roll
and now want to taste you this is
amazing this is my childhood memory game
it's like you know licking a zoom and
white dog poo well that sort of stuff
what happened to white dog poo it's one
of life's mysteries isn't it it just
disappeared get out of here Junior you
aren't even old enough to remember
around the late 1980s that's anyone
until then it was a thing you'd normally
would not add any liquid at all to the
interior of a pasty
Harrogate makes its own Raven clotted
cream scourge right oh my goodness you
know what you're doing here Cornish
purists are gonna be having kittens at
this huh oh they'll be up in arms
I've got dry time it doesn't need much
how about the white pepper how much of
that would you put in there when you've
got your ingredients seasons in a bowl
put a plate over the top now that's done
the job actually plenty of flour on the
table yes it doesn't stick turn and roll
and you want a circle around 15
centimeters across
paint milk from the outside to make it
sticky when you want to stick it
together you put a small handful of
filling in the middle pull the sides up
and pinch them together where you wet it
with the milk this is this old myth that
when they made the Cornish Pasties they
make them so tough that the miners wives
could take them to the mine head and
drop them down the mine I don't think
they have to be that tough anymore but
you do want to make a substantial crust
and the technique for closing them
you're just kind of bringing it up to
the middle to the ends meet and you
pinch those together once and kind of
fold back what you've done on itself
mine looks a bit like a fighter which is
almost the entirely wrong my camera
operator is grimacing at this the stay
of my pasty that's not the most
attractive looking pasty I've ever seen
but I suppose it's more about how it
tastes right that's what I keep telling
myself anyway so I'm now going over to
the meat filling online do you put
anything on the outside of it glaze it
yeah you can use milk egg wash is
possible just with your fingers better
you're not sure you would pay for it
Moon's fighting talk sick burn oven at
200 degrees 40 minutes you're looking
absolutely superb ordinarily use my
voice right into them it's not annoying
but it's got a little bit of a
cross-section first of all I've got I
still got steam coming off it you've not
let it cool for about 10 minutes let's
give it a go the miners would have had a
cold right to pop you just burn the roof
of your mouth that's pretty good yeah
put it I want the fish ones there
because it's I'm quite excited by oh the
cheese nanny opacity is absolutely
delicious
the only thing I might add to it if I
were to do it again maybe be a little
mustard so now I'm going for the the
veggie take on the the Cornish another
Cornish the Cornish style we should say
thank you yes yeah that's really good
pasties were my dad's favorite food he
was an absolute pasty obsessive and he
used to a part of his job used to drive
all over the country but he used to know
everywhere he could get a decent pasty
they've always liked me think of that
and I think you would have been proud of
these there's no better compliment than
that even the fish won't she wouldn't
have a crouton so tasty and and not just
something for the journey home from the
pub actually a really satisfying
lockdown
[Music]